kenny's with us in jefferson city hi
kenny welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave ramsey thank you for taking my
call
sure what's up so my main question
is do i finish do we finish the baby
step 2 step
now that i have no job i recently was
let go from my employer
the day before thanksgiving i made 90
thousand dollars
roughly as a physician assistant we made
a household income of
roughly 120 my wife currently still
works as a registered nurse and with
the status of the pandemic she's able to
pick up quite a bit of hours she makes
48 to 54 dollars an hour um
in the past two years we've paid off 70
000
roughly wow um and we had plans to
finish
uh baby step two right before the new
year
uh paying that last 16 000.
however we feel like we just were racing
towards the finish line and we got
tripped up
right before and we're really eager to
pay it off uh the
interesting things is that we have ten
thousand dollars
in our emergency fund right now uh
eleven thousand if you count the starter
emergency fund
uh we don't have health insurance
currently because my wife works as an
as needed basis and we have a
little one who's 11 months old and
we're waiting to hear back from a
fellowship that i applied to earlier in
the year
what is the fellowship what's that going
to get you set up for
the fellowship would give me some more
confidence
and would be it nice on the resume
to be able to give me future employment
i'm a new grad pa
and one of the reasons that they let me
go at my current job is that i felt like
i did not have the experience i needed
and was not meeting expectations
sounds like the meeting expectations was
the bigger issue right
yeah i think those expectations had to
do with
the experience portion
so you get ten thousand how long were
you employed
since so eight or ten months
yeah ten months
i think you go get another job i do too
i think you're just
i think you got knocked on your butt and
you got the wind knocked out of you
and i think you go get it you'll get
re-employed
i think the fellowship is an escape
mechanism for you
yeah fellowship's fine but it's a later
we need a now plan
yeah and no i wouldn't pay off the debt
until you re-employed but i'd be
re-employed before christmas if i were
you
a pa can land a job right now dude even
if you were fired for
um a level of competence issues
there's other other ways you can apply
your pa in situations and still
be and be competent enough to justify
your role so i'd go get another job if i
were you
what do you think absolutely two jobs
yeah
or three yeah and then i would pay off
my debt